in the moment 50 years in the making
here we go
michael strahan just said bye bye to
that signature gap between his two front
teeth
on tuesday the good morning america
co-host shared
that video sitting in the dentist chair
revealing that his friends
fans and business partner have all told
him to leave his signature tooth gap
as is if i go home and say i'm gonna do
it it'll be don't do it if i
post it'll be don't do it if i talk to
my friends if you don't do it without my
business whatever you like don't do it
but i got to do what i want to do for
myself now you know
you're the only one who knows no we're
just going to show them hey you're the
best at this stuff when i'm here yeah
well he did it and that's exactly what
he captioned the clip
alongside the hashtag goodbye gap this
is gonna be great
and while michael loves his new look i
love
it the reaction to it was mixed some
fans slid into the comments to say they
were sad he was getting rid of one of
his signature features
while others were convinced this was an
april fool's joke
which actually would kind of make sense
since he posted the video
two days before the holiday but others
were
all about the change and praised his new
smile
yeah yeah in 2018 michael talked about
embracing the gap in his teeth
after lonnie chavis who plays young
randall on this is us
posted a video in response to people who
are making fun of the gap in his teeth
if y'all kids are watching this like
don't trip be
be who you want to be i mean do what you
want to do
do you be you believe in yourself
at the time michael reposted lonnie's
message
alongside the caption quote you are an
inspiration my man
you make me proud to rock my gap and
your message
is exactly on point no one is perfect
and who really wants to be life is so
much better when you can relax
and be who the good lord made you it
feels incredible
and back in 2012 the former nfl pro
opened up to l
magazine about why he once considered
closing his gap
and then later changed his mind quote
for me
i made the conscious effort to say this
is who i am
i'm not perfect i don't want to be
perfect
for now we'll just have to wait to see
if michael's new grin
is permanent or if it's a prank but we
gotta say
he looks good either way
you